now another 627 deaths with coronavirus
have been confirmed in UK hospitals
taking the total to thirty two thousand
six hundred and ninety two Laura bun doc
is in the newsroom for us so just break
down these figures for us Laura yeah
Matt we've got the figures for all four
nations so if we take a look at England
first of all in England we know that a
further three hundred and fifty people
are confirmed to have died taking the
total number of deaths in the nation's
hospitals to twenty three thousand seven
hundred and nine the Midlands was the
worst affected area in the latest
figures with 78 fatalities earlier on
Scotland reported another 50 deaths
bringing their total to nineteen hundred
and twelve Wales recorded 16 more deaths
its total now standing at eleven hundred
and thirty-two and there have been nine
more deaths in Northern Ireland the
total in Northern Ireland 447 now it's
interesting that figure for the
Department of Health does seem quite
high six hundred and twenty seven more
deaths we know that if you look at the
figure in England that three hundred and
fifty daily increase a hundred around
100 of those are deaths which happened
more than a week ago so that might
account for that larger number but it
does seem to be a bit higher we know
that the Department of Health figures
are now taking into account not just
deaths from people who have died you've
tested positive for the virus in
hospital but also those who've tested
positive outside hospitals so in care
homes particularly in the community as
well but that does seem to be quite a
big increase in the daily number of
deaths we know that the true figures we
need to wait a little while for they're
the ones that come out with the office
for national statistics and these are
the figures that take into account both
confirmed cases and suspected cases as
well it also breaks down exactly where
the deaths are happening in hospitals
care homes in people's homes in the
community as well and that's really
important to see the different trends
overall now what we are starting to see
is that in all settings deaths are
beginning to fall we knew they were
falling in hospitals but they had been
creeping up in care homes as well in
care homes they are now starting to
decrease - which will be a great relief
I think to the care sector because
they've been a big fear for some
that while deaths in hospitals were
falling which meant the pressure on the
NHS was easing the pressure was very
much there for care homes I think it's
still there clearly but it is starting
to ease off